un golpe de estado frustrado las
autoridades de sudán informaron que los
rebeldes pretendían apoderarse de un
edificio estatal de medios de
comunicación
lo que ha sucedido es un golpe
orquestado desde dentro y fuera de las
fuerzas armadas se trata de un nuevo
intento de los remanentes del antiguo
régimen de impedir la transición
democrático civil
antes el lunes manifestantes de la tribu
veja habían bloqueado carreteras clave
también por sudan el principal centro
comercial del país protestaban contra el
acuerdo de paz firmado en 2020 entre el
gobierno y grupos rebeldes también
pedían la autonomía del este de sudán
hemos tomado una decisión con respecto a
las negociaciones y exigimos el derecho
a la determinación al sin embargo el
primer ministro relaciona los bloqueos
con seguidores del dictador derrocado
omar al bashir acusado en la corte penal
internacional de crímenes de guerra de
lesa humanidad y genocidio de genes y
tomaremos medidas inmediatas para
fortalecer la transición y desmantelar
el movimiento del 30 de junio que
todavía representa una amenaza para la
transición
sudán se encuentra en transición desde
2019 cuando unas protestas terminaron
con el gobierno de al bashir quien se
encuentra en una prisión de alta
seguridad sin embargo el país arrastra
graves problemas económicos que
provocaron reformas duras para la
ciudadanía una transición con un
gobierno cívico-militar que se espera
que termine en 2024 con elecciones